doris bures will be wir wollen zum maß
der rote planet stellt uns menschen vor
einer der größten herausforderungen
aller zeiten wie schaffen wir es einen
flug im all
über mehrere monate zu überstehen und
dann auf einem lebensfeindlichen
planeten eine neue zivilisation zu
gründen
naja eigentlich gar nicht man müsste
unzählige tests unter vergleichbaren
bedingungen durchführen was aber hier
auf der erde eigentlich nicht möglich
ist wie wäre es also wenn wir erst mal
auf dem mond landen das ist mehr oder
weniger die idee des artemis programms
bis 2019 sei die nasa eine rückkehr zum
mond vor 2028 eigentlich als
unrealistisch an
doch auf drängen der letzten us
regierung wurde ein neuer plan
ausgearbeitet kann doch eigentlich alles
ganz so schwierig sein oder
immerhin ist die nasa vor über 50 jahren
schon mal auf dem mond gelandet die
erste landung wurde also um vier jahre
vorverlegt und ein neuer finanzplan
wurde aufgestellt
doch wie sich herausstellt hat dieser
plan einige schwerwiegende probleme was
braucht man also alles um im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert zurück auf
den mond zu kommen und wie finanziert
die nasa diese unglaubliche mission
genau das erfahrt ihr im heutigen video
auf traktor watson und wir werden
übrigens noch mindestens ein weiteres
video zu den missionen machen wenn ihr
die also nicht verpassen wollt dann
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke dann werdet ihr direkt
benachrichtigt sobald wir das video
veröffentlichen
[Musik]
bayern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
naja kommen 7
freundin system
[Musik]
2020 war für viele echt nicht einfach
gerade erst hat eine studie ergeben dass
circa ein drittel aller unternehmen
mitarbeiter in kurzarbeit schicken
mussten
wenn ihr dazu gehört dann habe ich jetzt
gute nachrichten denn unser sponsor für
dieses video tags fix hilft euch eure
steuererklärung zu machen und so
hoffentlich geld vom finanzamt zurück zu
bekommen und das bis zum 31 märz
komplett kostenlos für alle die 2020 von
kurzarbeit betroffen waren wie ich finde
ein wirklich sehr cooler akt der
solidarität denn normalerweise kostet
139 euro 99 seine steuererklärung mit
tags zu machen und das auch nur wenn ihr
mehr als 50 euro vom finanzamt zurück
bekommt aber viele können das geld
gerade einfach dringend gebrauchen also
ist wirklich eine gute aktion
wer es nicht kennt taktik stellt hier
durchschnittlich 70 fragen die alle
super einfach formuliert sind und
schickt dann für dich alle daten ans
finanzamt und berechnet auch direkt wie
viel geld die voraussichtlich zurück
bekommen wirst im durchschnitt sind das
wenn man geld zurückbekommt über 1000
euro und dabei dauert das beantworten
der fragen nur 22 minuten ist schon sich
also wirklich
und als letzter bonus mit dem ersten
link unten in der video beschreibung und
dem kot watson alles in großbuchstaben
bekommt ihr noch einmal 15 prozent
rabatt wenn ihr überhaupt was zahlen
müsst und hier unterstützt damit auch
unseren kanal so dass wir mehr und
bessere videos machen können und so was
mache ich normalerweise nicht aber es
könnte gerade wirklich menschen helfen
wenn ihr jemanden kennt der von
kurzarbeit betroffen ist und oder
dringend geld braucht dann weist sie
doch auf diese aktion hier hin denn
seine steuererklärung nicht einzureichen
ist verschenktes geld
we are going das ist der leitsatz des
atem des programms so oder so ähnlich
lautete das motto aber auch schon vor
über 50 jahren bei der ersten
mondlandung we choose to go hieß es
damals
die mission in den 60ern eine
zurschaustellung der technischen
überlegenheit ein tauziehen zwischen den
usa und der sowjetunion
wer schafft es zuerst dafür wurden
damals keine kosten und mühen gescheut
heute im jahr 2021 hat sich das blatt
allerdings gewendet die nasa muss für
jeden cent ihres budgets kämpfen und der
einzige der auf eine schnelle besiedlung
des mondes gedrängt hat ist er
inzwischen ehemalige präsident donald
trump er und seine regierung haben der
nasa im märz 2009 10 eine förderung
zugesichert und die organisation dazu
aufgefordert ihre pläne zum
die siedlung zu beschleunigen
ursprünglich sollte die bemannte mission
nicht vor 2028 stattfinden
unter der leitung von jim breitenstein
entwarf die nasa aber einen neuen plan
um die ersten menschen schon vier jahre
früher wieder auf den mond zu bringen
die operation bekam den namen artemis
die griechische göttin des mondes und
der jagd und übrigens auch die
zwillingsschwester von apollon ok klingt
ja soweit alles ganz gut die nase
bekommt mehr budget und soll damit ihre
ziele deutlich früher erreichen
dazu gehören die erste frau und dem
nächsten mann auf den mond zu bringen
dort dann eine mondbasis zu errichten
und von dort aus dem nächsten jahrzehnt
zum mars zu fliegen
aber fangen wir mal ganz von vorne an
das gesamte atems programm besteht aus
fünf großen säulen
den anfang macht das space launch system
oder auch sls aussagen der nasa zufolge
soll es die stärkste rakete der welt
werden mit der auch flüge zum mars
möglich sein sollen
zweitens orion das ist das raumschiff in
dem die astronauten fliegen werden
welches ebenfalls später für die reise
zum mars genutzt werden soll
drittens die exploration ground systems
also alle teile die für den staat von
der erde aus benötigt werden
viertens das 100 gateway quasi eine mini
es im orbit des mondes die als
zwischenstation für missionen dienen
soll
und zu guter letzt die luna länder
kapseln mit denen auf dem mond gelandet
wird daran arbeiten aktuell firmen die
blue origin und space ex das klingt ja
alles mega spannend und unglaublich
aufregend aber direkt von anfang an ging
auch die ersten sachen schief schon seit
beginn des projekts gab es immer wieder
verzögerungen und planänderungen manche
davon sind einfach der komplexität der
aufgabe geschuldet die mondlandung plant
man halt nicht mal einfach eben nebenbei
aber andere sind klar auf entscheidungen
der nasa und auf die der us regierung
zurückzuführen
schauen wir uns das ganze noch mal etwas
genauer an und starten mit der
entstehung des space launch system
[Musik]
das sls ist der wichtigste teil der
mission und auch der der die meisten
probleme verursacht fertiggestellt soll
das sls tiefer ins all reisen können als
je eine rakete zuvor
es soll missionen zum mond zum mars und
sogar noch weit darüber hinaus
ermöglichen das sls nutzt als
hauptantrieb für rs 25 triebwerke ältere
versionen davon kam übrigens auch schon
beim space shuttle zum einsatz
die erste version der rakete soll eine
schubkraft von 39,1 mega minuten haben
was sie zum start so wahrscheinlich
antrieb stärksten rakete der welt machen
wird das starship von spacex soll nach
fertigstellung sogar auf 72 minuten
kommen das wird aber wahrscheinlich erst
2023 fertig frühestens zusammengesetzt
ist das sls größer als die
freiheitsstatue genauer gesagt 98 meter
und dieser koloss kann zum start ganze
27 tonnen an fracht in den orbit des
mondes transportieren spätere version
der rakete sollen dann sogar noch mal
doppelt so viel dass kapazität besitzen
aber alleine im jahr 2009 10 wurde das
beantragte budget von knapp zwei
milliarden dollar um 33 prozent
überzogen
nach berechnungen der aufsichtsbehörde
die die nasa überwacht wird das budget
in den kommenden jahren noch deutlich
weiter ansteigen
ursprünglich wurde das sls als reaktion
auf die einstellung des space shuttle
programms im jahr 2010 entwickelt da das
equipment veraltet war damals während
seiner amtszeit kündigte präsident
george hw bush das constellation
programm an aus dem später dann artemis
wurde schon damals war der plan den mond
und später auch den mars zu besiedeln
die nasa braucht aber einfach zu viel
geld und zu viel zeit weshalb barack
obama in seiner amtszeit das ganze
projekt wieder ein stampfte gut nur die
entwicklung am uri und raum schrift
weiter laufen durfte stand jetzt hat das
sls mehr als 17 milliarden dollar
verschlungen
im vergleich dazu das budget der nasa im
jahre 2020 lag bei 22,6 milliarden
dollar
und das gilt für alle missionen und alle
forschungen insgesamt schnell wurde aber
klar dass es keinen wirklichen sinn
ergibt ein neues raumschiff zu
entwickeln ohne eine rakete die es ins
weltall befördern kann
2011 begann man dann unter dem finalen
namen space launch system weiter an der
trägerrakete zu arbeiten
damals wurde der erste unbemannte flug
von sls und orion für 2017 und die erste
bemannte mission für 2021 wert gelegt
naja was soll man sagen hat nicht so
ganz geklappt aktuell ist der erste
unbemannte flug von orion und dem sls
für ende dieses jahres geplant die erste
bemannte mission frühestens ende 2024
übrigens schon in einem unserer letzten
videos zum starship haben sich viele von
euch gefragt warum macht es sich die
nasa so schwer und nimmt sich ein
beispiel an zum beispiel space extra
raketen wiederverwenden können denn das
private raumfahrtunternehmen hat schon
mit raketen wie der verein gezeigt dass
sie einfach effizienter und
zukunftsorientierter arbeiten können die
antwort darauf ist aber leider nicht
ganz so einfach
die nasa ist nun mal eine staatliche
behörde die durch steuergelder
finanziert wird jeder cent den die nasa
ausgibt muss vor einem aufsichtsrat
gerechtfertigt werden wenn sie eine neue
mission plant oder ein raumschiff bauen
will dann müssen alle kosten vor
projektbeginn vor kalkuliert und dann
bewilligt werden als das sls kalkuliert
wurde konnte noch niemand raketen wieder
aufrecht landen und dann wieder
verwenden das sls aber jetzt so
anzupassen dass auch dieser natürlich
sinnvolle schritt möglich wäre wäre ein
bürokratischer alptraum wenn es neue
entwicklungen in der technik oder
sinnvolle trends wie zb das
wiederverwenden von raketen gibt dann
kann die nasa darauf halt einfach nur
langsam oder teilweise sogar gar nicht
reagieren sonst kommts dass die
budgetüberschreitungen und mehrfachen
verschiebungen
das gefällt dann der aufsichtsbehörde
nicht und am ende wird ein projekt
vielleicht sogar auf eis gelegt wie das
ja zb beim constellation-programm
passiert ist
orion das deep space exploration
raumschiff der nasa es bietet platz für
bis zu vier astronauten und ist
ebenfalls für missionen bis zum mars und
sogar darüber hinaus ausgelegt orion
besteht aus drei separat entwickelten
teilen dem service modul in dem auch der
antrieb verbaut ist dem crm modul und
der spitze ecke dem launcher board
system
darüber hinaus ist das raumschiff auch
noch mit solar panels ausgestattet um
sich auf langstreckenflügen mit strom zu
versorgen die entwicklungsgeschichte
habe ich ja eben beim sls schon kurz
angerissen und wie gesagt auch hier
liegt definitiv nicht alles nach plan
für die fertigstellung und
weiterentwicklung von orion in den
jahren von 2006 bis 2030 wurden
zusätzlich 17 5 milliarden dollar von
der nasa beantragt ohne anzugeben wo
führt die genau gebraucht werden
das wurde natürlich stark von der
aufsichtsbehörde kritisiert und wer
schon mal seine steuererklärung zu spät
eingereicht hat der weiß vater staat
versteht bei geld überhaupt keinen spaß
stand ende 2020 wurde das budget von
orion um 900 millionen dollar überzogen
und diese zahl wird wohl bis 2023 noch
auf 1,4 milliarden ansteigen
orion soll das erste mal während atem
ist 1 zum einsatz kommen das wird ein
unbemannter testflug um den mond herum
und das soll noch dieses jahr passieren
im bericht der aufsichtsbehörde steht
aber auch dass weitere verschiebungen
wahrscheinlich sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die exploration ground systems sind
quasi alle strukturen und gebäude die
für den staat von sls und orion von der
erde aus notwendig sind ganz vorne oder
eigentlich ja ganz unten mit dabei der
mobile launcher ml war also diese
fahrbare start vorrichtung ja dieses
ding kann man fahren keine ahnung
welchen führerschein man dafür braucht
auf der plattform wird die rakete
zusammengesetzt getestet orion wird
installiert und der staat wird
vorbereitet und ist also ziemlich
wichtig diese plattform danach wird das
sls mitsamt raumschiff an der spitze zum
launch pad gefahren und wir jetzt hier
an mortal engines drängt oder vielleicht
auch nicht der film war ja eigentlich
aus dem flop der liegt gar nicht so
falsch denn die inspiration für die
fahrenden städte kam tatsächlich von
genau solchen mobile plattformen die
echten kolosse wie zb dieser hierfür das
sls wiegen knapp 5000 tonnen
zum vergleich das schwerste flugzeug der
welt mit gerade mal 640 tonnen bei so
einem kleinen und unwichtigen teil kann
ja eigentlich gar nichts schief gehen
oder
zitat modifikationen kosteten bisher 693
millionen dollar also 308 millionen
dollar mehr als geplant und die
fertigstellung hat sich bis jetzt schon
um drei jahre verschoben
naja immerhin weniger als die 17
milliarden beim sls muss man der nase
auch zugute halten
das gateway ist mein lieblingsteil von
artemis und soll quasi eine raumstation
im orbit des mondes werden an der
raumschiffe wie orion andocken und
astronauten sogar für kurze zeit leben
können sollen sie soll als wichtiges
bindeglied zwischen der erde und den
missionen auf den mond und später auch
auf dem mars fungieren astronauten der
artemis missionen sollen dort andocken
und in einen luna länder steigen mit dem
sie dann auf dem mond landen können
aber dazu später noch mehr das gateway
soll in einem ganz bestimmten orbit des
mondes schweben damit es von der erde
mit nur minimalem treibstoff einsatz
angeflogen werden kann führte mit 3 also
die erste bemannte mond-mission soll das
gateway nur mit dem nötigsten
ausgestattet sein
nachdem es drei soll die stationen dann
stück für stück erweitert und ausgebaut
werden
doch auch hier ist aktuell noch nicht
ganz klar wann und vor allem ob die
teile für das gateway fertig werden denn
es soll in modulen in den orbit geflogen
werden und sich dann im weltall selbst
zusammenbauen ziemlich krasser sei
falsch stand jetzt ist die nasa mit
entwicklung aber so weit hinterher dass
es gut sein kann dass die rückkehr zum
mond komplett ohne das gateway
stattfinden muss der nutzen einer
raumstation im orbit des mondes wurde
schon von mehreren seiten kritisiert der
zweite mensch auf dem mond apollo 11
astronaut buzz aldrin zum beispiel steht
dem gateway sehr kritisch gegenüber er
hält es in der aktuell geplanten
funktion für absurd
es ergebe aus seiner sicht keinen sinn
einen zwischenstopp einzuplanen
nur um die astronauten dann in einen
länder umsteigen zu lassen für eine
mondlandung ist das gateway auch
tatsächlich nicht zwingend erforderlich
das weiß auch die nasa aber auf lange
sicht insbesondere für weiter entfernte
missionen zum mars ist das gateway
durchaus sinnvoll
aktuell sollen die wichtigsten teile im
januar 2024 in den orbit des mondes
geflogen werden
ob ein luna länder dann direkt mit
geschickt werden kann ob sich das
gateway wirklich im weltall von alleine
zusammenbauen kann und ob dann wirklich
einsatzfähig ist all das steht noch in
den sternen
sonst muss es erstmal ohne funktionieren
auch da ist übrigens die
aufsichtsbehörde nicht besonders
optimistisch
[Musik]
die luna länder sind dafür gedacht
astronauten auf der oberfläche des
mondes zu landen
darüber hinaus sollen die mission
mitglieder in ihnen bis zu einer woche
lang leben können aktuell sind drei
modelle bei unterschiedlichen firmen in
arbeit
als erstes wäre da das sogenannte
national team was mit blue origin an der
spitze ein dreiteiliges landes system
entwickelt das system besteht aus einem
antriebs einem lande und einem transfer
module origin ist das
raumfahrtunternehmen von amazon gründer
jeff bezos das aktuell auch noch an
einem kalender arbeitet er also nur
fracht transportieren soll
beide systeme werden parallel entwickelt
und laufen unter dem projektnamen glühen
wie auch schon beim gateway sollen sich
die drei teile erst im weltall
zusammensetzen und von da dann ihre
mission antreten da hinkommen sie
übrigens nicht mit dem sls sondern mit
der new democrat die blue origin selber
entwickelt und bevor ihr fragt ja die
soll auch wieder verwendbar sein
der zweite länder wird von der firma
dynamics entwickelt der nötig ist ein us
amerikanisches unternehmen das unter
anderem technologien für
raumfahrtunternehmen und das
verteidigungsministerium der vereinigten
staaten herstellt die waren zum beispiel
auch am bau der moab beteiligt der
mother of albums der sprengkraft
stärksten konventionellen fliegerbombe
der usa alle mp3 spieler wissen jetzt
gerade was ich meine
aktuell arbeiten sie an ihrer version
eines wiederverwendbaren human landing
system und das sieht so aus erinnert
mich ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen an
den hasen müsst ihr ein bisschen was man
so mit den ohren da nötig schreibt sich
selbst auf die fahne einen komfortablen
länder zu entwickeln und nicht nur auf
funktionalität zu setzen immerhin sollen
die astronauten hier auch wohnen können
human centered design nennt sich dieser
ansatz dafür arbeitet die firma mit
ehemaligen astronauten wie zum beispiel
dem ball zusammen
der war pilot des space shuttle atlantis
welches bauteile zur iss geflogen hat
wenn sie vielleicht mal ein eigenes
video übrigens zudem human learning
system oder auch generell zur
entwicklung von raumschiffen oder
raketen sehen wollt dann lasst mich das
gerne mal in den kommentaren wissen
vielleicht machen wir dazu mein
komplettes eigenes vieh
last but not least spacex ja auch allen
masc möchte astronauten auf dem mond
landen aber wer hätte es gedacht elon
hat natürlich mal wieder ein komplett
eigenen ansatz spacex baut einfach da
keinen länder also stimmt nicht so ganz
nehmen nämlich dass starship und
modifizieren es so dass quasi ein länder
eingebaut wird aber wie das genau
funktionieren soll und wie die
astronauten dann vor allem auf die
oberfläche des mondes kommen das ist
noch nicht so ganz klar
denn das ist ja sehr hoch und die crew
kapsel ist ganz ganz oben und ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass sie dann
einfach runter springen die 100 liter
oder wie viel das sind auch wenn die am
montag 9 6 die gravitation hat aber es
kann ja nicht sicher sein
es gibt so eine animation von spacex da
fahren die mit so einer art fahrstuhl
runter sieht es allerdings nicht so noch
so ganz krass im zwei schicht aus
[Musik]
also lasst uns noch einmal
zusammenfassen das sls wird hoffentlich
dieses jahr fertig einen test der
triebwerke gab es immerhin schon der ist
aber schief gegangen aktuell sind drei
versionen von orion im bau und die erste
ist hoffentlich ende diesen jahres
fertig um sich auch die artemis 1
mission zu begeben
die exploration drohen systems müssen
sogar noch vor dem sls fertig werden
damit die rakete überhaupt zusammen
gesetzt werden kann
hier ist man aber immerhin vorsichtig
optimistisch anders sieht es da beim
gateway aus wenn es überhaupt bis 2024
zum einsatz kommen kann dann nur in sehr
reduzierter form und selbst das ist
aktuell unwahrscheinlich
die größte hoffnung würde ich jetzt mal
persönlich in die luna länder setzen
weil die größtenteils unabhängig von
privaten firmen entwickelt werden
aber wenn der nasa das geld ausgeht bzw
das nicht bewilligt wird dann kann es
auch hier zu verzögerungen kommen aber
gehen wir mal davon aus dass alles
klappt vielleicht nicht perfekt es gibt
leichte verzögerungen das wird ein
bisschen teurer aber die mission
enthalten ihre starttermin um 2021 2022
und 2024
was passiert dann wie genau laufen atem
ist 13 ab und wie geht es danach weiter
wie kommen wir zum mars genau das
erfahrt ihr schon bald in teil 2 das
video kommt in den nächsten wochen wenn
ihr das früher vor allen anderen sehen
wollt dann unterstützt uns entweder
aufhören oder auf doktor watson tv auch
da könnt ihr videos von uns früher sehen
und wenn ihr das video einfach nur nicht
verpassen wollte hier auf youtube dann
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke damit ihr immer informiert werdet
wenn wir was neues hochladen
ansonsten wie immer viel leid fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig patrick